let's go to your voicemails I have two
voicemails today both of which have to
do with Trump not wearing masks of
course our voicemail number is two one
nine to david p anytime you get a
hankering to call in feel free the
voicemail number works 24 hours a day
Eastern Time that's a joke let's go to
the first one let's take a listen
together
David this is Dave from California the
president doesn't get it
he won't wear a mask we need to explain
it in language he can get right why
don't
reporters just tell them the mask is
like a condom sure it will help you
spread disease and help you not get a
disease maybe they need to dumb it down
to that level no no it's actually I
think that this next caller is spot on
with her analysis I didn't even think
about this take a listen to this very
interesting yeah my opinion is I think
Donald Trump doesn't wear a mask because
it might sweat off some of that orange
stuff on his face right he took it off
he probably looked like an orangutan
that didn't occur to me but Trump's
spray tan would get all over the mask
imagine the embarrassment of taking the
mask off and it's all orange and some of
the orange is removed from his face that
actually maybe given what we know about
Trump one of the reasons of course it's
the management by optics he can't be
seen wearing a mask wearing a mask would
imply that there's a risk of catching
the virus out in the public which of
course there is as we see from millions
of global cases etc etc but I like the
idea we have a tremendous bonus show for
you today
Brazil's pind pandemic is just beginning
and we may end up finding someone who
actually is handling the corona virus
pandemic worse than Trump and that would
be the Brazilian President Jo bolson ro
who happens to be one of
Trump's buddies Brazil is in really
rough shape the worst response in South
America and the one that Trump seems to
most identify with interestingly enough
number two San Francisco has confirmed
that they are giving limited quantities
of drugs recreational drugs to homeless
people living in hotels there are people
on the right who are outraged there are
people who say this is harm reduction
and it makes sense we will talk about
that on the bonus show and then lastly
JetBlue the airline JetBlue wants to
salute frontline workers by a flyover
with low-flying planes planes over New
York City and New Yorkers were
understandably annoyed about it I have
stories about low-flying planes from
when I lived in New York City I will
tell them to you on the bonus show today
get the bonus show by becoming a member
at join pakman.com or becoming a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
and in the meantime please make sure you
sign up for our sub stack newsletter you
can sign up at david pakman.com or at
david pakman.com it's the free daily
newsletter which will be morphing into a
daily written digest of the David Pakman
show
very exciting free free free sign up on
our website david pakman.com and I will
speak to you so soon on the bonus show